[Musique]
2022 par car l'olive maire de Poissy
vice-président du conseil départemental
et hauteur de ce beau pays qui est le
mien c'est ballon bonjour Caroline
bonjour Patrice carboz et bienvenue
sur mon téléphone je vous la montre ne
pas vous la connaissez ouais je la
connais bien maintenant c'est la lucarne
c'est la lucarne voilà c'est le c'est le
coup franc enveloppé qui va dans la
lucarne et qui tombe sur la tête d'un
monsieur qui prenait sa douche
l'année 2022 par ça c'est que ça va être
une bonne année
oui puis c'est aussi ça s'inscrit dans
le cadre du rapport que que je rends
demain
à Nadia la ministre de la Ville qui m'a
commandé un rapport sur l'insertion des
jeunes au travers du sport dans les
quartiers et là on est à Évry non loin
d'ici dans les quartiers au cœur des
quartiers et je suis allé valoriser des
expérimentations de terrain comme quoi
vous voyez on a des jeunes qui proposent
aux uns et aux autres de venir faire un
tir dans la dans la lunette dans la Lulu
dans la lucarne et sans prétention on a
échangé on a revu ces jeunes parce qu'on
souhaite évidemment que cette lucarte
face école et l'équipe de Malamine
Sissoko a été formidable pour moi c'est
c'est Patrice Clermont d'ici à Poissy on
a trois quartiers populaires la Coudraie
Beauregard et Saint-Exupéry ce qu'on
appelle des qpv des quartiers de la
politique
dans la famille mon papa a fait 42 ans
Chrysler mais quatre frères ont fait
l'école Chrysler à l'époque la mixité
sociale était au pied d'immeuble c'est
un petit peu j'ai voulu revoir ici c'est
formidable de valoriser ses quartiers ou
bien souvent il faut le dire ils sont
stigmatisés alors il y a aussi une
symbolique
votre amour du sport du football
président
1000 emplois pendant la durée des
travaux 250 millions d'investissements
cercle vertueux de l'économie locale le
football le handball et le judo il a
encore c'est le Paris-Saint-Germain qui
vient Sarcelles non pas à côté de Poissy
mais dans Poissy au cœur du territoire
et ça c'est formidable et puis il y a
quelque chose d'autre dans ces images
c'est le respect tout d'un coup voilà
vous êtes en train
de me demander pourquoi j'étais pas venu
en survêtement avec ce qu'on appelle les
copains mondial vous savez non là c'est
presque
quand vous aimez les gens je le dis
souvent ça s'apprend pas dans le
dictionnaire il faut les respecter les
gens si vous voulez être respecté moi je
suis ravi d'avoir vu ces jeunes faut
être sérieux sans se prendre au sens
prendre au sérieux et je pense que c'est
aussi un message envoyé à à tous les
élus quel qu'il soit de temps en temps
c'est bien de respirer c'est bien de se
détendre et quand vous envoyez un gramme
on vous les rankilo vous le dites
d'ailleurs dans le dans ce livre ce beau
pays qui lui vient c'est page 67 je veux
avoir des clés de droit de pouvoir
pousser la chansonnette d'aller jouer au
foot de courir en forêt de me faire
chambrer par ma femme et mes enfants
voilà c'est pas parce que on se prend
pas tout le temps au sérieux qu'on ne
fait pas des choses sérieuses là c'est
ça oui puis l'épidémie Patrice Carmaux
vous le voyez bien l'épidémie nous a
montré que il y avait une relativité
aussi à voir faut aussi prendre un peu
de recul on est les plus heureux du
monde quand on s'engage alors c'est pas
un métier être mère mais c'est une
fonction quand on est né dans sa ville
qu'on a grandi dans sa ville et
qu'aujourd'hui on a la chance de
partager sa passion avec les 40000
administrés je veux pas dire dans la
moitié mais quand j'étais en short mais
c'est juste formidable il faut
relativiser donc de temps en temps c'est
c'est vraiment je revendique
effectivement le droit de courir avec
mes amis de chanter avec mes amis et de
faire des tirs dans la lucarne avec avec
des jeunes dans les quartiers
qui vous font c'est d'abord des valeurs
dans lequel vous êtes attachés et puis
c'est aussi un certain optimisme on peut
si on veut on doit on doit pouvoir y
arriver quoi l'optimisme de la volonté
comme on dit d'abord les valeurs et vous
l'avez dit je vous le disais moi mes
parents étaient de la classe 34 on était
on était 8 dans la famille
malheureusement j'ai perdu la moitié de
ma fratrie mais on a toujours été élevé
dans dans le respect dans le respect de
notre beau pays dans le respect de notre
beau pays je le dis dans le bouquin on a
une tradition dans la famille mon père à
chaque fois qu'il y avait la
Marseillaise devant la devant la télé
sur des événements quel qu'il soit il
était debout il avait les larmes aux
yeux aujourd'hui quand il y a la
Marseillaise on est toujours debout en
famille et c'est important de la chanter
c'est aussi ça c'est ce devoir de
tradition ce devoir de transmission et
aussi de fierté pour ce beau pays
ou raconter d'ailleurs dans le livre
vous avez été choqué au match France -
Algérie quand la marseillais bien sûr
bien sûr qu'on est choqué parce que
siffler la marseillais c'est pas
simplement siffler la Marseillaise c'est
quelque part habiter à abîmer la
République et quel que soit les
personnes qui sont ici elles sont nées
ici elles sont françaises avoir avant
d'être quelle qu'elle soit et on a ce
respect qu'il faut avoir pour notre pays
ça commence par là ça commence pas en
fait l'application de la règle là le
respect des valeurs et pour qu'on
applique les règles je le dis dans
l'ouvrage il faut les connaître ses
règles et c'est et c'est important que
de rappeler les règles moi je les
rappelle à mes agents trois fois par an
que je réunis presque 1000 ici dans le
dans le dans le théâtre pour ajuster ce
que nous pouvons ajuster mais comme dans
le sport Patrice soit vous êtes dans le
jeu soit vous êtes en dehors du jeu et
quand vous êtes en dehors du jeu dans
les sports c'est ce qu'on appelle un
hors-jeu hors-jeu loi 12 au football on
lève la main c'est un coup franc direct
sans quelque sorte une sanction mais
je regrette que que encore une fois ici
en France certaines et certains quel
qu'il soit façon blanc de connaître les
règles ou n'applique pas la règle parce
que souvent c'est plus facile de faire
l'autruche et mettre la tête dans le
sable c'est pas mon cas et je pense que
la France aurait besoin vraiment
d'assumer le fait que il y a des règles
et qu'on les appeler ce livre il part
d'un coup de colère maintenant
les gens qui râlent tout le temps de
leur situation vous citez cette cette
phrase de Sylvain Tesson à la France en
enfer c'est bien ça ça vous agace
oui ça m'agace et j'aimerais que que
lorsqu'on a la chance de pouvoir voyager
on voit aussi ce qui se passe dans ce
qu'on appelle les comparaisons avec avec
l'étranger quand avec ce qu'on appelle
du benchmark moi typiquement l'été
dernier j'ai passé quelques semaines
j'adore l'Espagne et la Costa Blanca je
peux vous dire que le respect
l'imposition du masque était pas à
géométrie variable il fallait porter le
masque
elle venait quand elle intervenait elle
demandait pas si on était d'accord pas
d'accord où on était on n'était pas on
n'est jamais aussi français quand on est
à l'étranger l'un de mes garçons qui
s'appelle Quentin qui a 26 ans qui est
footballeur professionnel il revient de
Bulgarie je peux vous dire qu'il
m'explique comment notre beau pays est
un paradis et ça c'est important de se
le dire c'est pas l'analyté c'est pas de
l'angélisme c'est simplement de se dire
ok c'est compliqué c'est pas simple on a
une épidémie qui a été draconienne mais
pour autant le plan de relance quoi
qu'il est quoi qu'il en coûte le le fait
d'avoir mis le pays sous cloche pendant
des mois a fait que 3/4 des entreprises
continuent à survivre aujourd'hui et ça
tout n'est pas parfait mais c'est bien
de se le rappeler de temps à autre vous
dites vous êtes français vous êtes fier
d'être français mais vous dites si je
peux considère pas plus français que que
mon copain Moussa qui est d'origine
Rodez ça aussi c'est important c'est à
dire que c'est aussi ça la France c'est
considérer que d'autres peuvent devenir
la France la France c'est un pays
bigarré la France est une terre
color il faut il faut en être
particulièrement fier on est très riche
de notre diversité et c'est juste
formidable ce qui n'enlève rien le fait
d'accepter les valeurs qui sont les
nôtres quand on est quand on vit dans
notre beau pays quand on vit dans notre
beau pays on a des règles à respecter on
a des raides à appliquer ce que
j'appelle la réciprocité entre les
droits et les devoirs et cette règle-là
elle concerne tout le monde y compris
parfois des jeunes qui se croient tout
permis dans les quartiers c'est pas les
stigmatiser c'est juste faire un constat
je vous donne quelques exemples il m'est
arrivé ici la nuit de voir des jeunes de
12 ans fracassés des abribus c'est pas à
12 ans en pleine nuit on fracasse pas
des abrimus la place du jeune à 12 ans
pendant la nuit elle est chez lui donc
il y a un vrai sujet du rapport à la
famille du rapport à l'éducation et
encore une fois du rapport finalement au
respect de tout à chacun dans ce beau
pays qui est notre doudou elle vient
justement cette contestation de
l'autorité quoi parce que c'est ça la
contestation de l'autorité viens d'un
laxisme Patan qui date depuis une
vingtaine d'années ou malheureusement
par défaut peut-être de moyen la justice
a été non pas moins efficace ce serait
un bien grand mot mais elle est plus
lente entre guillemets à déléguer non
pas parce que celles et ceux qui
appliquent la justice le soir pas du
tout c'est qu'elle manque de moyens
aujourd'hui ça va mieux mais on avait
parfois jusqu'à 24 mois des attentes de
décision et quand on attend 24 mois une
décision sur une peine bah parfois le
jeune a retrouvé du travail donc cette
décision tombe de fête ou pas
aujourd'hui ce qui est bien c'est qu'il
y a plus de rappel à la loi parce que on
s'est souvent fait chambray nous autres
élus par des jeunes qui avaient un
rappel à la loi et qui vous manque qui
vous montrer le rappel à la loi qui
rentrait dans leur quartier que le V de
la victoire ils ont voilà moi j'ai fait
ma garde-à-vis j'ai mon rappel à la loi
et je peux recommencer demain là ça
change et tant mieux moi je salue le
travail d'un côté qui est fait par
Gérald Darmanin on l'a vu ici à Poissy
avec le comité et notamment le fait
d'intégrer peut-être qu'on en reparlera
les cautions mariage dans la loi si tu
viens de m'annoncer le fait que le garde
des sceaux monsieur Dupont-Moretti est
accepté l'initiative du territoire
viltigeur que les villes s'arrochent les
tiges et dans le rapport que je rends à
madame la ministre je propose que les
tiges
qui répondent à des délinquants mineurs
qu'on fait une incivilité puisse être
par exemple régler dans les clubs les
clubs de sport ça c'est intéressant et
donc ça ça va dans le bon sens donc tout
n'est pas encore une fois parfait mais
je pense que ce laxisme patent fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a une société qui
continue d'être fracturé et qui n'a
qu'une envie c'est quelque part se
retrouver sur des valeurs communes et
qui sont le fondement finalement de la
France alors vous le dites aussi il y a
quand même parfois des blocages qui
existent pas faute d'argent public parce
que l'argent dans la politique de la
ville elle a été mise l'argent dans les
hôpitaux mais on voit quand même que ce
qu'on appelle
l'ascenseur social il est souvent en
panne et vous
faudrait peut-être s'interroger dessus
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que on
arrête typiquement de de stigmatiser
celles et ceux qui n'ont pas eu la
chance ou non pas les moyens finalement
d'être à bac + 5 ou à bac + 12
j'aimerais que l'apprentissage soit
valorisé et vous le voyez on est à
700000 apprentis là on a longtemps été
sous la barre des des 400000 moi je
crois l'apprentissage typiquement
Patrice Cameroun je pense que
l'apprentissage est un passeport pour
l'emploi c'est certainement pas une voix
par défaut et c'est une manière aussi de
valoriser celles et ceux qui n'ont pas
eu la chance de faire ce qu'on appelle
les grandes études moi j'ai un cabinet
ici comme à l'époque où j'étais Canal+
ou un Canal+ par exemple au cours de mes
5 années de direction j'ai embauché 80
jeunes entre 18 ans et 25 ans qui
n'avait pas été formé au métier du
journalisme mais qu'ils sont devenus par
l'apprentissage et la
professionnalisation et aucun n'est sur
le carreau c'est ça que j'aimerais dans
ce dans notre pays c'est qu'on montre
que la porte est ouverte à celles et
ceux qui savent ouvrir les portes de qui
peuvent même les défoncer encore faut-il
qu'ils aient envie de travailler encore
faut-il qu'ils aient envie de travailler
et moi je souhaite évidemment que
au-delà la respectuité dont j'ai parlé
Patrice entre les droits et les devoirs
il y a intérêts aller travailler plutôt
que rester chez soi
vous racontez pourquoi oui il y a des
gens qui vous disent attendez moi je
joue tout 700 avec le RSA pourquoi
j'irai bosser pour 200 € par mois 300 €
l'équivalent pour faire 35 heures donc
ça ça ne peut plus durer parce que ces
jeunes ne comprennent pas alors que
leurs parents ont parfaitement compris
et aujourd'hui nos aînés qui sont en
retraite mais se disent mais il marche
sur la tête pendant 40 ans ça a été le
cas chez moi mais mais dans nombre de
familles évidemment personne n'était en
arrêt de travail il y a jamais eu de de
maladies où il fallait vraiment être à
l'article de l'amour comme on disait
pour s'arrêter de travailler aujourd'hui
ça évidemment tout ça changer je remets
pas en question cela je suis simplement
que à un moment donné c'est bien que
celles et ceux qui travaillent soient
valorisés par rapport à celles et ceux
qui ne travaillent pas de fait qui
bénéficie
et tant mieux parce que la France est
faite ainsi et on va pas revenir dessus
mais faut pas que l'accompagnement
devienne assistanat il faut pas que
l'assistanat prenne le pas sur cette
valeur travail dont on parle tellement
alors ça c'est un peu le constat et puis
il y a des solutions pour proposer vous
parlez de la méthode ko qui est celle-là
mise en place à Poissy beaucoup
d'emperisme vous dites d'ailleurs
il faut être comme les tortues de
Galapagos pour pouvoir s'adapter aux
situations qui sont en face de nous oui
il faut s'adapter parce que la situation
il y a encore il y a encore 10 ans on
n'est pas la même évidemment
qu'aujourd'hui et typiquement si on
m'avait dit en 2014 lorsque la première
fois que j'ai été élu qu'aujourd'hui
j'aurais autorisé l'armement de ma
police municipale jamais sur écru et
pourtant c'est une évidence et pourquoi
c'est une évidence parce que Charlie est
passée par là le Bataclan est passé par
là et aujourd'hui les voyous les
terroristes ne font pas la différence
entre un policier municipal non armé et
un policier national qui lui est armé
donc aujourd'hui tout le monde
il y a plus débat et il y en avait eu
comme la mise en place des caméras vidéo
protection
donc il est important de faire
comprendre et de bien comprendre que
c'est à nous à nous adapter et pas
l'inverse avec des bienfaits je prends
le cas par exemple des vaccinations
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé quand en 24
heures grâce à docteur Lehmann on décide
de transformer une salle des fêtes à
Poissy le sort de diffusion artistique
en centre de consultation qui est
aujourd'hui le 1er centre de vaccination
en France depuis le 7 Janvier 2021
bah en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'on a on a vu que l'hôpital public
arrivé à travailler avec la médecine
privée ce qui n'avait pas été forcément
le cas avant que la ville était
facilitateur et qu'on s'est retrouvé à
créer presque des familles avec la
grande famille des centres de
vaccination je pense aux réserve
citoyenne et communale je pense aux
agents de la ville je pense aux
infirmières je pense au médecin et ça ça
a été formidable tout ce qui ne tue pas
rend plus fort comme on dit c'est
l'adaptation c'est du Darwin j'ai plein
de tortues si je vous le montrerai tout
à l'heure ça fait partie voilà je pense
au Portugal faut qu'on soit Darwin
peut-être cette crise sanitaire parce
que justement on a appris vous avez
appris
le comment travailler avec l'étape
travailler là où l'État est passé
parfois difficile aussi de proposer des
solutions ça peut-être que ça a changé
aussi l'image qui était déjà bonne dans
la population mais justement des élus
locaux de mer voilà voilà ce qu'il
pouvait faire c'était concret c'était
sur le terrain c'était là vous avez tout
à fait raison le 15 mars
2000-2020 ici un dimanche on a été élu à
75 % on aurait pu faire la fête ensemble
et cetera à 22h on était dans ce bureau
le lendemain on était ici et ce bureau
est devenu en quelque sorte une
Samaritaine il y avait des casques avec
des préparations culinaires on avait des
visières on avait commande qui avait été
faite pour pour les vaccins avec des
piles de documents et en fait on s'est
aperçu que on était sur le front sur le
front de guerre on s'est pas posé de
questions on a fait 7 sur 7 et on a vécu
cette pandémie cette bataille contre la
maladie qui était une maladie inconnue
contre cette ennemi invisible comme
comme un immense j'en ai encore
l'émotion un immense élan de solidarité
ici vous voyez sur la place de la
République tous les jours à 13h la
réserve citoyenne avec des gilet jaune
des vrais beaux gilet jaune
s'employer à aller faire les courses
pour les aînés qui n'avaient aucune
nouvelle de leur famille ça a été
formidable on a passé 12000 coups de
téléphone pour veiller veiller sur eux
et c'est vrai que cette épidémie a créé
des choses nouvelles et à montrer ce
jeudi dans le bouquin que le coq
français ne chante jamais aussi bien que
quand il habite dans la merde c'est vrai
et c'est la vérité et c'est la vérité il
a montré plein de choses d'abord on a
montré jeudi dans bouquin que le chameau
ça bosse c'est qu'en France on est les
plus heureux du monde merde on est les
plus heureux du monde
pas le savoir arrêtons arrêtons et ça
c'est aussi important je crois de de le
rappeler tout n'est pas simple on peut
évidemment améliorer plein plein de
choses enfin de grâce voyons ce qui ce
qui a été fait et comme le dit vous le
disiez c'est le 20 et son la France ce
paradis peuplé de gens qui se racontent
en enfer
mes contacts
que quand on aime les gens on n'est
jamais déçu
que quand on aime les gens les les
Français sont capables de tout entendre
ce qui va ce qui va pas aussi enfin ce
qu'il souhaite avant tout c'est qu'on
puisse leur dire en face pas au travers
de courrier pas au travers d'appel qui
ne viennent jamais pas au travers de oui
on en reparlera non c'est voilà ces
réunions publiques plus de 100 réunion
publique en 6 ans on en prend plein la
figure on en prend plein la gueule on se
dit au bout de 2h ou 3h c'est pas
possible on va jamais s'en sortir et on
fait 75 % aux élections les Français
aiment ça ils aiment ce contact ils
aiment dire au voisin ah j'ai vu le
maire aujourd'hui je lui ai mis une
gifle par rapport à ce qui nous avait
dit ou ce qu'il a dit lui
aimer les gens ça s'apprend pas dans le
dictionnaire
respecter les gens pour moi c'est
l'alpha l'alpha Omega de ce qu'on doit
faire et puis toujours être le premier
dire bonjour c'est l'opération bam
bonjour au revoir merci
ben voilà c'est c'est formidable et
c'est pas compliqué tout le monde peut
être mère à une condition c'est d'aimer
les gens
ça ça me paraît très important
de la République s'il a fallu que je
respecte monsieur le Président et tout
le respect que je vous dois votre
protocole sanitaire à la con qui fait 70
pages il y a pas une école de France
si on ne prend pas sur nous d'être force
de proposition ce que je dis au
Président c'est Kennedy le président
Kennedy disait ça Nathan ne vous
demandez pas ce que vous ce que l'État
peut faire pour vous demandez-vous ce
que vous pouvez faire pour l'État et
avant cela que puis-je faire pour ma
commune pour faciliter le quotidien de
mes c'est ça mon ambition moi mon
ambition c'est la porte d'entrée c'est
l'administrer comment je peux faciliter
le quotidien de mes administrés mais
typiquement de façon très simple d'abord
en rappelant les règles et l'une en les
appliquant de 2 et en faisant en sorte
d'être finalement dans la justice et
dans la justesse sociale je me permets
d'insister dessus exemple le pouvoir
d'achat on donne 30 € à celles et ceux
qui veulent faire du sport ou de la
culture quel que soit leur condition de
ressources quelque soit leur condition
de ressources entre 12 et 17 ans le
retour ou le revers de la médaille c'est
qu'on se comporte normalement c'est du
pouvoir d'achat mais si jamais vous
faites des incivilités à côté j'ai aucun
état d'âme à suspendre ou supprimer et
les Français ne comprennent très bien il
est hors de question qu'une minorité
vienne polluer le quotidien d'une grande
majorité c'est simple à expliquer alors
dans cette optimisme disons de solution
aussi il y a aussi l'idée de vivre
ensemble ou presque plus de réussir
ensemble dans dans votre
[Musique]
l'exemple du Paris Saint-Germain à
l'avenue du centre d'entraînement du
Paris-Saint-Germain est un exemple
péremptoire sur ce sujet Patrice Carouge
le Paris Saint-Germain j'ai joué au
Paris Saint-Germain ma sœur qui est
présent du comité olympique a joué au
Paris Saint-Germain elle était manager
du Paris-Saint-Germain comme vous le
savez j'étais pas trop d'espoir à Canal
je travaille aujourd'hui à la Ligue de
football professionnel mais si le
président du Département pierre Bédié
n'est pas là si la région Île-de-France
va les Pécresse n'est pas là si la
communauté
urbaine n'est pas présente si les
habitants ne valide pas ce projet il y a
pas de centre d'entraînement du
Paris-Saint-Germain on est c'est terminé
je crois et c'est un bon enseignement ça
aussi la crise cette structure
râteau ou chacun joue dans son couloir
c'est fini ça on est dans une structure
pyramidale
il faut bien comprendre
et on a aucune difficulté à revendiquer
le fait que c'est le fruit d'un travail
collectif et pas seulement celui d'un
maire d'une ville quelle qu'elle soit
vous dites
cette question comment remettre l'église
au centre du village alors comment on
fait on simplifie on a ce fameux choc de
simplification il passe par une chose la
confiance c'est se faire confiance en
latin comme fiaret on fait avec on fait
ensemble et quand on fait on fait pas
les uns à côté des autres on fait pas
les uns derrière les autres on fait pas
les uns contre les autres on fait
ensemble parler du sport le sport c'est
un vecteur exceptionnel par rapport à
cela on parle de sport santé on se parle
de Sport Emploi on parle de sport
insertion on se parle on parle de sport
citoyenneté de sport compétition de
sport loisirs de sport famille s'il y a
quelque chose qui rassemble aujourd'hui
qui a sauvé des vies Patrice Carmouze
c'est bien le sport le sport c'est un
catalyseur social Versailles et moi je
pense que à 2 ans de ce magnifique
rendez-vous pour la jeunesse les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024 dont
nombre d'épreuves auront lieu dans notre
beau département qui est département des
Yvelines c'est l'occasion magique de
faire nation par le sport et j'espère
bien qu'on s'y en pourra proposer des
jeux olympiques du sport de la culture
oui bah oui pourquoi pas il y a pas il y
a pas raison je pense qu'il faut qu'on
soit force de proposition ici on a une
terre d'expérimentation on est venu on
nous déclare comme tel comme on dit on
reconnaît comme tel et c'est ce qu'on
souhaite mettre en place avec les
collègues et amis de génération terrain
cette association d'élus ou on
revendique le fait d'être sur des
échanges d'idées qu'on peut mettre en
place alors ici vous le savez à Poissy
on a on offre 2h de sport aux agents par
semaine dans le cas du temps de travail
750 jours de d'absenterissement moins
amélioration des conditions de travail
mais typiquement il y a un fond de
dotation que Saint-Germain-en-Laye à mis
en place pour les mécènes et les
entreprises c'est aussi une très très
belle idée on a un sujet sur les taxes
de friches commerciales pour mettre bien
assez à ses propriétaires qui sont qui
sont des ogres parfois des données des
données privées de de se gargariser
alors qu'ils sont trop en matière de
loyer donc on les taxe quand les les
commerces ne sont pas loués pendant 2
ans 30 % 40 % de taxe foncière
supplémentaires et aujourd'hui on a 99 %
de notre artère principale qui est
occupé grâce au à l'attaque sur les
friches commerciales un mot sur ce
rapport que vous allez le remettre sur
les insertion des jeunes par le sport
dans les quartiers oui vous le disez
d'ailleurs votre mode c'est faire
national par le sport jouer tout tous
ensemble
alors il y a je crois qu'il y a 24
propositions oui on a 24 préconisations
on a fait trois mois de 3 mois de
déplacement de visite moi je voulais que
le terrain parle c'est l'ADN vous avez
fait 120
on est allé voir
des jeunes des jeunes associatifs des
présidents de club évidemment des
institutionnels on a vu le Comité
olympique on a vu les Jeux Olympiques on
tu as différents mères mais on a vu
surtout des préconisations qui
paraissent tellement simple on a vu les
bailleurs et à titre là le le Premier
ministre a accepté de m'inviter au
comité interministériel à la ville à
Grenoble qui a eu lieu il y a 2 semaines
maintenant et je lui ai présenté trois
premières préconisations qu'il a accepté
la première c'est les sérieux sportif
c'est quoi c'est les bailleurs qui ont
des friches au pied d'immeuble des
espaces qui sont pas utilisés bah
typiquement on les met à disposition
d'une association et de la ville et on
les occupe en faisant du sport quand il
y a plus de 150 m² on peut y mettre un
dojo il y a le projet de 2000 dojo
solidaire porté par la Fédération
française de judo et son président
Stéphane novice moi je souhaite
l'élargir avec des tiers-lieux sportifs
pour faire de la relaxation pour
permettre aux femmes et aux jeunes aux
jeunes demoiselles dans les quartiers
qui aiment bien faire la boxe par
exemple de faire de la box éducative
dans ces espaces ça c'est le premier
sujet le deuxième sujet on a nombre
aujourd'hui il y a 1500 quartiers en
politique de la ville en France on a
donc de collectivités qui sont
labellisés cité éducative par Nadia
Émile de la ville je souhaite que on
puisse élargir ça au sport si tu es
éducative via des contrats locaux de
sport et pourquoi pas créer des sports
exactement
les tiges par le sport voilà trois
préconisations sur 24 mais il y en a
d'autres la généralisation par exemple
de l'ouverture des gymnase et des écoles
le soir et le weekend parfois il y a pas
de créneau pour les associations
faisons-nous confiance mets-toi en place
un triangle d'or entre la ville
éducation nationale et les associations
et vous allez voir il y a plein de
petites choses qui coûtent pas cher qui
viennent exclusivement du terrain et qui
peuvent être mises en place concrètement
dans les dans les deux semaines qui
viennent
politique
depuis 2017 à parler du football tout à
l'heure
d'Elton John en
2014 et on n'a jamais voilà on sait
jamais quitté voilà c'est une relation
de proximité et d'amitié et c'est aussi
je dirais un contrat très fluide entre
nous ou quand j'ai quelque chose que je
souhaite faire remonter je ne pose pas
la question de savoir si ça va plaire au
présent République ou pas je me dis ça
va plaire ça va rendre service il me
semble au président et si ça rend
service au président peut-être que
humblement ça peut rendre service à mon
beau pays on a l'impression que cette
oui c'est une rencontre
voilà vous avez réfléchi quoi
c'est un chemin
par rapport par rapport aux autres c'est
un choix proactif par rapport à la
personne qu'il est par rapport à ce
qu'il dégage et aussi il faut le dire
par rapport à ce que je considère un
bilan qui est un bilan bien louable ou
aujourd'hui on est sur un plus bas
niveau historique en terme de chômage on
va descendre sous les 8 %, on a une
croissance historiquement haute on a des
millions d'emplois qui ont été créer
l'apprentissage qui a fait un bon
spectaculaire on a eu un plan de relance
qui a permis ses spécialiste qui le
disent près d'un an et demi de de gagner
pour nos entreprises encore une fois
tout n'est pas parfait tout peut-être
amélioré moi ce que je souhaite c'est
que le président s'appuie encore plus
sur celles et ceux qui sont en prises
direct avec la réalité du terrain
c'est-à-dire les maires ce qui lui a
manqué au cours des deux premières
années 2004
justement
peut-être oui il y a quelque chose qui a
changé et je pense là encore la crise
sanitaire a dû changer beaucoup les
choses je crois qu'il y a une bascule
Patrice Clermont en décembre 2018 et
juste avant le grand débat qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé on a été un certain nombre
de maires on n'a pas été les seuls avec
Génération terrain on était 15 à être su
à l'Élysée avoir dit au président on a
bien compris que la France a besoin
d'être réformée d'ailleurs présent vous
avez été c'est pas le présent mais vous
avez été ému
mais la manière pour parvenir assez
réformes et juger catastrophique sur le
terrain donc il faut remettre le
logiciel à l'endroit et commencer par le
terrain et il nous a dit j'ai bien
compris moi j'avais ajusté parce que
j'avais ajouté c'est une de mes formules
bretonnes cher à ma petite maman qui
n'est plus là mais je pense à elle
présente allez sentir le cul des vaches
et c'est à vous de le faire et donc le
grand débat est parti comme ça et
j'invite moi j'ai souvent suggéré
inviter le président à multiplier les
rencontres avec les Français sur le
terrain les rencontres avec les mères
quel qu'il soit parce qu'un maire ne
peut pas tricher un maire ne triche pas
quelle que soit sa sensibilité politique
une triche pas c'est un sérum de vérité
par rapport au contact qui peut avoir
avec ses administrés au quotidien quels
sont les grands sujets que de la France
dans les 5 ans qui viennent le pouvoir
d'achat
le pouvoir d'achat je dis dans dans la
préface posthume que je que je que je
dédie que j'avais rencontré il m'avait
dit la France
c'est le pouvoir d'achat c'est aussi la
sécurité on a besoin d'avoir une
sécurité ou l'autorité de l'État ne se
dément pas et ne se dés de voilà on ne
triche pas ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières semaines on a vu le convoi
soi-disant des libertés il y a eu
vraiment une fermeté de la part de
Gérald darmerie et n'oublions pas que la
sécurité c'est le premier des libertés
moi je suis un défunt rouge défenseur
des forces de police des forces de
sécurité qui font un travail formidable
ces gens-là ont été farcis pendant les
gilet jaune toutes les semaines de
Koh-Lanta comme j'aimais appeler ou il y
avait des dégâts partout et cetera on a
pu tenir un peu le pays grâce à ces
personnes là il faut il faut pas le rap
il faut pas l'oublier et donc je le
rappelle sans cesse donc pouvoir d'achat
sécurité on va avoir un sujet évidemment
sur la santé notre système de santé est
à bout de souffle il va falloir
massivement investir sur ce sujet
augmenter les salaires de celles et ceux
qui qui sauvent des vies au quotidien
parce que sans elle ça devient très
compliqué ça deviendra très presque
obsolète et puis derrière comprendre que
encore une fois et je le dis pardon mais
on a tellement de choses qui nous
rassemble à côté de tout ce qui nous
divise ici en France comprenons-le et
c'est comme ça qu'on sera encore un peu
plus puissant et légitime à l'endroit de
l'Europe dans un premier temps et du
monde ensuite
quelle part vous allez prendre dans la
campagne
celle que voudront bien donner celles et
ceux qui la façonne en tout cas je crois
que le fait de d'apporter des solutions
concrètes de pas tout attendre de l'état
de proposer des choses on parlait tout à
l'heure des cautions de mariage où on
capte un chèque de caution de 1000 €
courant après aux mariés évidemment mais
si jamais il y a des débats et des
incités
et donc on fait remonter je disais tout
à l'heure Patrice les deux heures de
sport le contrat gagnant-gagnant entre
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et puis il y a un vrai sujet c'est celui
d'éducation je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut qu'on rattrape le tard en matière
d'éducation il faut se libérer des des
carcans de la tradition ou voilà il faut
qu'on il faut qu'on se détende aussi
j'ai envie de dire ça en matière
d'éducation et faire en sorte
typiquement que le sport la culture
l'économie puisse faire partie
intégrante de l'éducation dès le plus
jeune âge voyez par exemple aujourd'hui
on a des des personnes en situation de
handicap lorsqu'elles sont jeunes et
qu'elles veulent faire du sport ne
peuvent pas faire du sport parce que les
aides aux personnes en situation de
handicap qu'on retrouve à l'école ne
sont pas formés pour pouvoir accueillir
des jeunes qui veulent faire du sport
c'est un petit exemple on a besoin de
formation on a besoin d'éducation qui
fasse que ce soit véritablement l'école
de la vie qui fasse grandir encore plus
notre pays
sortant de la 12e circonscription
Florence Granger se représente pas c'est
quelque chose à quoi vous pouvez penser
d'abord je crois que Florence granju
elle a fait un travail de de terrain
dans la partie qui était la sienne
notamment sur
laquelle il y a Poissy
sur l'emploi qui a été un travail qui a
été loué par par les autorités
législatives et ça faut sans féliciter
Florence Anjou est constate aussi mais
comme nombre de députés et il faut le
savoir que l'engagement c'est un
engagement difficile aujourd'hui d'être
élu combien d'élus sont menacés combien
d'élus ils sont insultés Florence
bourgeois elle patite ça aussi elle a
elle a été menacée elle voit bien que
que l'engagement est un engagement de
tous les temps puis il y a des décisions
aussi qui sont des décisions
personnelles donc je vous vois venir
aujourd'hui je pense que il faut pas
jouer
les législatives avant 2022 comment joue
pas 2027 avant avant
quelle connerie ce non cumule des
mandats quand hier on pouvait
alors moi aujourd'hui et moi je rends
hommage aux députés de son travail
législatif qui a été fait mais
franchement entre 2017 et 2019 nombre de
députés ont découvert la politique les
codes de la politique ont passé beaucoup
de temps à l'Assemblée beaucoup beaucoup
de temps et était totalement absent sur
le terrain et pendant 2 ans il y a eu
cette déconnexion ou nos seuls
interlocuteurs il faut le dire était les
sénateurs finalement et je pense que
c'est pour le coup c'est une vraie
bêtise non cumule des mandats on verra
le moment venu on verra le moment venu
je sais que aujourd'hui
plus beau mandat comme on dit c'est le
mandat de de mer et on le revendique je
le vois au quotidien maintenant
j'aimerais apporter effectivement ma
contribution ma pierre à l'édifice et je
voilà je m'interdis rien et puis quand
on a réussi quand on réussit dans sa
ville
de porter son ambition il y a beaucoup
de choses encore à faire le jardin est
pas totalement scruté
je ne ferai pas le mandat de trop et je
ne veux pas partir par là par la petite
porte
du Comité olympique français
de mes enfants le plus beau jour de ma
vie ah oui parce que ma petite sœur
était
était pour nous
on était donc c'est un garçon une fille
elle était la dernière les 5 garçons
voulaient devenir footballeur
professionnel on n'est jamais parvenu
même si on a joué des bons niveaux elle
a une qui est parvenue c'est elle
c'était la fierté de c'était la fierté
de de mon père qui voulait faire de ma
sœur une Nadia Comaneci chanteuse
olympique de gymnastique en 1976 et
finalement c'est devenu c'est devenu
l'artiste un du ballon rond une
vice-président de la Fédération
Française de Football et aujourd'hui la
première présente du Comité olympique
sportif français femme depuis sa
création en 1972 pour nous ma petite
sœur c'est c'est formidable j'ai ma
petite sœur parce qu'on a grandi
ensemble
oui ben je crois que mais dans la
famille c'est pas une question de
fonction c'est une question d'amour
fraternelle on est d'assonance bretonne
et quand on est 8 on était 8 autour de
la table on a toujours parlé la première
personne du pluriel jamais à la première
personne du singulier c'est aussi ce qui
je crois a fait notre force merci
beaucoup merci
[Musique]